in this video we're going to talk about
how to solve linear equations involving
fractions we're going to go through
three examples see if you can do these
on your own and you can compare your
work with what we're doing here together
but i just want to go over some
different suggestions here to help you
when you're solving these types of
equations so the first thing we want to
do here is we want to
simplify the left side of the equation
the right side of the equation then we
can proceed to step two which is to get
the variables and numbers on opposite
sides and lastly we want to solve for
just one of the variable so first step
we're just going to go ahead and
distribute that two-fifths
into the parentheses and remember when
you multiply a fraction
times a whole number you want to
multiply the numerators together
and the denominators together so i'm
going to say 2 times 10 is 20.
5 times 1 is 5
and same thing here 2 times 8 is 16 and
5 times 1 is 5. and i'll just bring down
that 12.
now 20 divided by 5 we know is equal to
4
okay so that's 4x
and then on the right side you can see
we still have a whole number 12. but our
goal is to get the variables on one side
the numbers on the opposite side so
that's step number two and so we want to
do here
is we want to
get rid of the 16 fifths and we're going
to do that by doing the opposite instead
of subtracting 16 fifths let's go ahead
and add 16 fifths
and you can see that
they're going to cancel one another out
because one's positive one's negative
but over here on the right side of the
equation you can see that
one of these fractions
has a denominator of five the other has
a denominator of one because remember
anything divided by 1 is itself so what
we have to do when we're adding
fractions we have to get that common
denominator see this one down here and
this 5 down here we want to find the
smallest number that both 1 and 5 go
into evenly
and in this case it looks like the
smallest number that they both go into
evenly is going to be
5.
so what we're going to do is we're going
to multiply this fraction
the numerator and denominator by 5
because remember when you multiply by 5
over 5 that's like multiplying by 1
because anything divided by itself is
going to be 1.
so now if i multiply horizontally the 12
times the 5 is going to give us 60. the
1 times the 5 is going to give us
5
and then we're going to add the 16
fifths to it so remember when you add
fractions you add the numerators but you
keep that denominator the same so you
don't want to add the fives and say
that's 10 you just add the numerators
and so now we're on to that last step
here which is to
solve for just one of the variable just
one x so we would say hmm how can i just
get this x by itself how can i get rid
of that four
well normally we'd see that the four and
the x are next to each other which means
that they're multiplied together but you
could say well what's the opposite of
multiplying by 4 that would be to divide
by 4
or what i like to do sometimes instead
of dividing when you're working with
fractions is think about
multiplying
by the reciprocal so i'm going to
multiply by 1 4
to both sides because again remember 4
is like 4 over 1
the numerators are going to and
denominator here are going to cancel
because 4 goes in here once 4 goes into
here once and we're left with 1
over 1 which is just 1x
so it looks like we're getting x is
equal to
76 fifths
76 fifths times 1 4th and again we can
multiply the numerators together
denominators together or we can do a
little bit of cross reducing 4 goes in
here once
4 goes in here 19 times and so we're
left with
19 fifths
and we can also write this as a mixed
number 5 goes into 19
three whole times with four left over
so we could say that x is equal to 19
fifths or three and four fifths
and you've got that first one done now
another suggestion another possibility
we could talk about is clearing the
denominators and we'll talk about that
in the next example so let's go on to
example number two
okay so for the second example you can
see that we have
variables on both the left and the right
side of the equation and our goal
remember is to get the variables on one
side the numbers on the other side of
the equation just think of that equal
sign as like a
dividing line okay so sometimes i even
like to draw a little dash or dotted
line and so it doesn't matter what side
you get them on as long as they're on
the opposite sides so i tend to like to
get the
variables on the left and the numbers on
the right but you can do it the other
way around that's no problem but the
technique i want to show you in this
problem is how to actually get rid of
those fractions all together and just
make your your problem solving here a
lot easier and so what i'm going to
recommend here that we do on this
problem
is we make every
quantity here every term into a fraction
if it's a whole number remember you can
put it over one and then what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
all these denominators and we're going
to ask ourselves what's the lowest
common denominator what's the smallest
number that 3 goes into 2 goes into 6
goes into and 1 goes into
and in this case the smallest number
that they all go into that lowest common
multiple is going to be
6. so what we're going to do is we're
going to take this whole equation we're
going to multiply the entire thing
by 6. now if you don't like that method
the way i've done it right here you can
also think of just multiplying the left
side of the equation by 6 and the right
side of the equation by 6.
keep in mind that 6 is the same as 6
over 1.
so when we go ahead and distribute that
6 into the parentheses we're going to
make sure we multiply
it to all the terms remember the terms
are separated by minus or plus they're
basically the the groups here
so
when we do that let's see we've got 6
times 5 is 30
1 times 3 is 3
and if we do that to the one half six
times one is six and one times two is
two
and over here on the right side six
times one is six and one times six is
six
and then six times three is 18
and 1 times 1 is 1.
okay so now what you'll notice is we can
reduce these fractions so 30 divided by
3 is just going to give us
10 x
6 divided by 2 is going to give us 3
6 divided by 6 is 1x or we could just
say x and 18 divided by 1 is just 18.
so the nice thing about this now is
we've cleared the denominators we've
gotten rid of those fractions it makes
it a lot easier to solve
but remember we're still solving
equations which means we want to get the
variables on one side the numbers on the
opposite side so what i'm going to do
here is i'm just going to
get the variables on the left now to get
the variables on the left another way of
saying that is you have to get rid of
them on the right so let's say i want to
get rid of that x right there how can i
get rid of it well i'm going to do the
opposite instead of adding x see that's
a positive x or adding x i'm going to
subtract x
from both sides of the equation remember
you always want to do the same thing to
the left and the right
to keep the equation balanced then i
like to just kind of think of it as an
addition problem i'm just adding
straight down here
bring your equal sign down keep
everything lined up that'll make it a
lot easier to just stay organized and
avoid making any mistakes now we've got
the variables here on the left we want
to get the numbers on the right so how
can you get those numbers on to the
right again you want to do the opposite
so instead of subtracting 3 we're going
to add 3 and remember whatever you do to
the left you want to do to the right
the negative 3 or the minus 3 and the
positive 3 cancel leaving us with 9x
18 and 3 is 21.
we're almost to our last step here we
want to solve for just one of the
variable just 1x
so what we can do here is instead of
multiplying by 9 let's just divide both
sides by 9. so if we do that the 9's
cancel
we get 21 over 9. keep in mind we can
try to reduce this fraction it looks
like
3 goes into both the numerator and the
denominator so if we divide the top and
bottom by 3
we're going to get 7 thirds
or 3 goes into 7 twice with one left
over so we could say seven thirds or
two and one third
so that's another way of doing it and
that's clearing the denominators by
finding that
lowest common denominator and
multiplying both the left and the right
sides or you can think of multiplying
the whole equation by that number to
clear the denominator
okay let's look at one more example see
if you can do this next one on your own
okay so for number three let's see if
you can do this problem i think what i'm
going to do here is i'm going to
approach it the same way that we've been
doing
before which is just to do the
distributive property so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to take that negative
2 7 i'm going to distribute it into the
parentheses and again keeping in mind
that any whole number
can be written as a fraction over one
like a number over one so we're going to
multiply the numerators together
and the denominators together
same thing here with the seven we're
going to multiply the numerators
together
which remember a negative two and a
negative seven those two negatives when
you multiply two negatives together you
get a positive
okay again multiplying the numerators
together denominators together and same
thing on the right side one times x is x
2 times 1 is 2 or you can think of this
as 1 half x
and then same thing here 3 times 1 is 3
and 2 times 1 is 2.
so now what we want to do is
i think this is kind of the nicest way
of doing it is go ahead and multiply by
that lowest common denominator we want
to clear the denominators just to get
rid of the fractions and we have to ask
ourselves a little question here we have
to say well
what is the
lowest common denominator so meaning
what is the smallest number that 2 goes
into and 7 goes into well it looks like
they all go into the number 14 that's
probably the smallest so we're going to
multiply the
left side by 14 the right side by 14.
you can see we're still keeping that
equation balanced
now i'm going to show you a little
another technique here that you can do
instead of multiplying the numerators
and denominators together
you can do a little bit of cross
reducing so what i'm going to do here is
i'm just going to
go ahead and look at this 14 and the 7 i
can see that they reduce so 7 goes into
14 twice
right
so what happens now is when i multiply 2
times negative 4 i'm going to get
negative 8 and then you can see 1 times
1 is just going to be 1 so i just get
negative 8x so what i'm doing is i'm
kind of reducing it
as i go
but one thing when you do it this way is
you have to be careful that when you go
back here
to distribute to the next term like when
we go to distribute this 14 to this
fraction here
we are going to want to
um
go ahead and basically remember that
this is 14 and it's not two you know so
we want to go back to that original 14.
so everything is being multiplied by 14.
now another way to
to look at this maybe that'd be a little
bit less confusing
is if you decide okay i'm going to
multiply through by that common
denominator 14 what you might want to do
just so you don't get confused is go
ahead right next to every one of these
terms go ahead and write down 14 over 1
14 over 1 14 over one like you're
multiplying every every term every group
every fraction by 14 over one so
that way just you won't forget that
you know that you're doing it to each
term then when you do it this way you
can see you can reduce 7 goes into 14
twice and when you multiply the
numerator together you get negative 8
denominator together you get 1 and of
course negative 8 divided by 1 is just
negative 8.
same thing here you can do a little
cross reducing
and we're going to get 28
and same thing here a little bit of
cross reducing we're getting seven
x and then over here a little bit of
cross reducing we're getting 21 so
that's a nice technique to get rid of
the fractions
clear those denominators and now it's
just more like a regular problem that
you're familiar with and so what i would
do at this point
is i would
go ahead and
get the variables on one side numbers on
the other side so what we're going to do
is we're going to get the
variables on the left and to do that we
have to get rid of them on the right
side so i'm going to get rid of them by
doing the opposite again make sure you
do it to both sides of the equation
and now what we want to do is want to
get the numbers
on the other side and the way we're
going to do that is instead of adding 28
we want to get rid of that 28 on the
left by
doing the opposite subtracting 28
so let's do that to both sides again i
like to keep it real organized keep
those equal signs lined up
sometimes i think students kind of get a
little bit lost in some of the
arithmetic and and that's an easy way to
kind of make a mistake so
try to keep everything organized right
neatly uh that helps as well just so you
don't misinterpret what you've written
okay and then when you can see i'm just
treating like an addition problem i'm
just adding straight down the 28s are
canceling and then the last step is
always to solve for just one of that
variable so we say hmm what's the
opposite of
multiplying by negative 15 well we want
to divide both sides by negative 15 or
the way that i like to think about it is
multiply by the
reciprocal so i would actually multiply
by a negative 1 15
to the left and the right sides this way
you can see that this is going to give
you 15s are going to cancel a negative
times a negative is a positive so that
just gives us x
here the 7 is like 7 over 1 and when we
multiply the numerators together we get
positive 7 denominators together we get
positive 15
and
you can see that's our final result we
don't have to reduce that any further so
great job keep working on your solving
equations involving fractions and i'll
see you in the next video